[Music]
and we're here today to talk about the
cost of a pixel specifically the colors
that you choose in your apps and how
they directly affects the battery uses
of your user devices so before we do
that we need to think about the actual
technology that goes into users devices
and stiffly the display technologies now
there are two prevailing con
technologies that are in most devices
LCD and OLED the majority of devices on
Android these days tend to be OLED
devices and OLED screens especially from
the mid mid levels is kind of high level
and even in sort of light over platforms
they slowly move into owner as well LCD
stands for a liquid crystal display and
they work very differently to an OLED
they work with what they call liquid
crystals so each pixel we made up of a
number of color channels of malikul
crystals the important thing to know
here is that they require a backlight so
those liquid crystals don't illuminate
themselves that requires a backlight
behind it to shine through the crystals
and that's how you see color now most of
the power for a LCD display goes into
that backlight they also see the actual
crystals don't require that much it's
the UH it's the backlight so more
brightness is more power overload are
different only displays are light
emitting diodes which as you can guess
actually emit light themselves so
there's no need for a backlight and
those pixel each pixel illuminate itself
and that's how the light shines out the
good thing here is that they allow a
true black so with a LCD the way you
achieve black is by turning all the
crystals on and then the light the back
light still shines through and so you
can never really get that really dark
true black oh let's complete different
in the way they LEDs work is they just
don't turn the pixel on and that's how
you get black so that's where the power
is and the power is dominated by
actually emitting the light so it's the
LED shining that actually is the power
there's no backlight is the actual LED
itself now there's a number of kind of
arrangements that displays can be made
in so if you think about pixel you tend
to have three channels are G and B and
that's the simplest arrangement each
pixel on your display will
three channels and that is true for both
LCD and OLED that both can have
different arrangements so that's my
straightforward and simply mentally
simple like you have one two three
there's also more complex ones
things like RGB are where you'll have
the all the channels we split across two
pixels and each pics will only have two
channels it's just a way of kind of
expanding pixel size without trying to
fit as many LEDs in now it's important
to think about because in terms of power
more LEDs equals more power usage so
here we've done a lot of stats over the
past kind of a year or two because we
know that users care deeply about their
battery life and the display tends to be
the biggest power user
power user of your device so you can see
a very straightforward chart which
here's the fact that the higher
brightness on your display the more
power it uses you know it's kind of
simple anyway like everyone assumes this
is the weight the case but the thing is
it's actually quite linear so again kind
of simple but then we started kind of
comparing our OLED devices or LED
screens versus LCD screens and in this
case it's the pixel versity iPhone 7 we
did with display no screenshot of maps
in both a normal day mode and a night
mode the reason we use a screenshot is
because we didn't want the differences
between say iOS or Android to conflict
with the power and just displaying a
screenshot it's just define an image so
this should be pretty similar on both
platforms but you can see with the
numbers that the iPhone 7 and the LCD
screen the actual milliamp per inch on
both night and day is the same it
doesn't change and that's because it's
an LCD screen and it does it can't like
make use of those dark pixels I love how
it uses anyway but on the pixel itself
because it's an OLED display the actual
power usage drops down by 63% which is
huge like a 6-3 percent of the biggest
power user on your device just by using
the dark theme but even going more into
it when you've got actual individual
pixel colors so we did a test where we
just displayed one color on the on the
on the display and the actual color
itself makes a big difference in power
so blue itself is 25 percent more text
25% more
then say green or red and then another
chart which is pretty much a summary of
the previous chart but isn't nice line
form but you can see that black is using
the least amount of power kind of Asuma
anyway and it goes up and over up until
we get white and because white uses
these channels from everyone it's full
red for green for blue
it requires the most amount of power and
guess which color we've been pushing you
towards over the past couple years
material came about or it was three
years ago and we change from holo which
is nice dark fame to this white feet
instead and we kind of shot ourselves
and foot slightly in terms of power so
it's like some case studies of Google
Apps over the past couple years or so
actually we should implement in dark
themes and the power savings they've
managed to have so first ones YouTube
here we have an example which you at
work you can't see the video plane but
it is and you can see that for back full
brightness just by switching to a dark
theme you say 43% of your battery usage
now when you playing a video the rest of
it underneath isn't so important anyway
so dark theme really works now when it's
paused we save even more it's 60% my
guess here is that because the kind of
overlay over the video actually darkens
the video and was you know we're using
even more dark colors so we save more
power now this test itself depends very
much in the video content if you have a
video which is fully white and then
you're not gonna say too much and Ouija
board
so tea balls actually a really good
example because this is something users
can control it would you now you can
switch to a dark theme and you can save
20% of your battery
well not 20% over the display you set
the battery just by switching to a dark
theme so it's actually quite a big thing
and finally on maps this is commonly the
canonical example of dark FEMEN where it
really is bright because he has the
obvious it's of the battery which is 31%
when it's on full brightness but it's
also usable like you don't want maps
being like a really white theme when
you're driving at night and glaring UI
so dark theme here really makes the app
the app more usable and the nighttime
setting and now Alan's gonna talk for
implementation
all right so how can we embrace the dark
side and implement dark mode in our apps
I'm going to dark theme which will not
save us any battery here but it will on
your devices so you may remember night
mode from the Developer Preview of
Android last year or your before that or
the year before that's or the year
before that but we we released day/night
support in app compat s-- which was
implemented by chris there's a great
blonde blog article about it our
recommended way to implement dark mode
in your app and basically get it for
free depending on how your themes are
architected is day night so if you're
using app compat you can get this almost
for free the stock widgets will respond
automatically to changes in the devices
night mode you can also manually toggle
between light and dark modes so you can
add a switch in your app and your app to
do this this is the demo from the
Android X checkouts if you have Android
X checked out from AOSP
takes five minutes you can run the app
compat demo and take a look at how this
is implemented it's basically one line
of code to switch between whatever theme
you're using before and app compat you
simply take whatever your app theme is
and have it inherit from one of the app
compat day/night themes and again
depending on how your app is architected
everything might just work you can also
apply a overlay theme dynamically at
runtime so if you want to have a pure
black OLED themes there there are some
apps that already do this or a pink
Hello Kitty theme or what-have-you
you can apply a theme dynamically at
runtime by just calling get theme dot
apply style and applying an overlay
theme if you want to learn more about
overlay themes Chris and I talked about
those at i/o a couple of years ago so
what that looks like is just overriding
activity dot set theme this ensures that
anytime a theme is set on your activity
you will then immediately overlay it
with the black theme or a Hello Kitty
theme or what have you and then any
views that get inflated will be using
that theme correctly alright
either way you're gonna want to
structure your app to rely on theme out
when I said depending on how your app is
architected this is what I'm referring
to all of the platform drawables heavily
rely on theme attributes to obtain their
colors so things like color foreground
color control normal color accent you've
probably seen the implementation of the
material track switch the the thumb
sorry the switch that you can drag left
and rights the thing that sits directly
under that is colored light gray when
it's enabled and dark gray when it's
disabled the implementation of that is
just a color selector a color state list
that refers to the color foreground
attribute from the theme which is white
under light theme black under a dark
theme and a disabled alpha which is also
defined by the theme so we vary that
based on light and dark themes you'll
notice there are no colors hard-coded
here and in general you don't want to
hard-code colors we'll talk about this
more later today in a talk with Nick
butcher about themes and styles right
so I mentioned night mode showed up a
couple of releases ago the night
qualifier has been in the platform since
SDK 8 it has always been there it was
opened up for general use in Android n
so the ability to set the night
qualifier system-wide there are some
apps now that accidentally set the night
qualifier system-wide if anybody noticed
messages doing that recently it's been
fixed so this is what you'll use for
switching your resources it's a resource
qualifier similar to portrait or
landscape you just create a drawable -
night or a values - night and if you
have resources that are difficult to
extract theme colors out of say you have
a welcome splash image that is very
complicated and you couldn't put it in a
vector drawable so your designer just
gave you a PNG and you can get a dark
version of that that has significantly
different colors and it's too
complicated to put in a vector drawable
you can just drop an alternate version
of it in drawable nights when the device
is in night mode or when your app is in
the app compat implementation of night
mode you'll pick up that drawable
automatically same thing for colors if
there are colors that you want to switch
say your accent color is slightly
brighter in a dark mode you can extract
that out to a color a named color
resource have one version in colors one
version in colors night I'm sorry values
night all right so here's what the theme
implementation can look like if you want
to switch your parent theme based on
night qualifier you simply define the
theme twice once in values once in
values night and give it a different
parents when your theme is referenced
under non night mode you'll pick up the
the light theme when it's referenced
under night mode when the night
qualifier is on you will pick up the
dark theme same thing goes for colors so
here we just have the same color defined
two different ways anytime that you
reference hard-coded FG it will pick up
black under non night mode it would pick
up white in night mode all right so what
can you do to update your app maybe do a
little bit of restructuring and make it
work really well for night mode well you
can start really simple just take a
screenshot of your app invert it see how
it looks I've get a sense of whether
there are images that you'll need to
have an alternate version of here we see
a bunch of avatars those we probably
want to keep the exact same maybe we
want to change the background colors a
little bit so that may mean extracting
theme attributes that may mean creating
some alternate values if they're vector
drawables or that may mean getting
different sets of PNG s to drop into
drawables night next you want to take a
survey of the usage of colors in your
layout XML and in your styles so go
ahead and set the parent of your theme
whatever your app or activity theme is
to be something dark themed up app
compat or theme material and see how it
works you'll want to look for issues
with losing contrast between foreground
and backgrounds not seeing dark colors
where you expect to see dark colors and
in general what you see should look a
little bit like that inverted screenshot
you'll notice here it looks nothing like
the inverted screenshot because all of
the background colors and foreground
colors were hard-coded to be like theme
the one thing that wasn't hard-coded and
you can almond
see it here is the label for first name
which is now invisible because it's the
only thing that's correctly pulling in
the dark theme color attributes so this
is going to require a lot of work the
hard part is doing that work so you'll
want to refactor your colors as much as
possible take any hard-coded colors in
your layout xml's
move those out to named color resources
you can split those based on values
values nights if you want to do more
than one type of theme maybe you have a
Hello Kitty theme you want to apply
dynamically you'll want to extract those
two color attributes that have some sort
of meaning in your application so as I
mentioned before we have text color
primary that's built into the platform
theme we have color accent we have color
primary so you should be using those as
much as possible and certainly take
advantage of theme attributes for
specifying colors propagating those into
your drawables into color state lists
into your layouts you can convert color
to your P and G's to alpha masks and use
tinting if you look at oh we don't have
a slide for that so you can wrap those
with a bitmap elements and set an alpha
and set a tint with Android colon tints
we'll talk again a little bit more about
this at the themes and styles talk later
today alright next you actually move
over to the app compat day/night theme
and you get automatic switching when the
device is in night mode you could also
consider adding a preference so here we
have the Twitter app I don't use Twitter
so much the Twitter app which has a very
obvious affordance for switching between
day and night so if you tap this it goes
into dark mode and it's really
convenient for your users
you'll also want to keep in mind that
there is a platform specified dark mode
so you may end up with a tri-state that
says inherit from the platform dark mode
or I can specify always dark or always
light you also want to test that your
application works when night mode
changes so you can toggle this manually
using ADB from the command line so open
up your app once you've implemented the
day/night theme
toggle it into
Knight yes your application should
preserve whatever state you had and be
recreated it's gonna go through a
full-on destroy and recreation and be
recreated in dark theme preserving user
data on pixels of pixel three devices
running P night mode will automatically
switch when the device enters battery
saver mode so that's another way that
you can test this you can also toggle it
directly from developer options and push
night to mode to be always on always off
or one of the the legacy things that we
support is switching based on time of
day you can also learn more as I
mentioned many times in the themes and
styles talk that'll be giving with Nick
butcher later today if you want to learn
more about the lower level things in
themes and styles Chris and I gave a
great talk a couple of years ago at
Google i/o so that covers everything you
want to know but have been afraid to ask
about themes and styles and if there are
things you're not afraid to ask we will
be outside in the Android lounge that
way to answer any of your questions so
thanks everybody for coming please
embrace the dark side
[Music]